welcome to the aperture science
competence center for our most gifted
employees
i'm cave johnson and if you're hearing
this you are exceptional
no don't be bashful it's true no false
modesty
let's get started
look at all those tubes stretching off
in the distance
every one of them's taking something
important to a genius who's going to use
it to change the world forever
a genius just like you
how are you going to change the world
well that's up to you
history will remember what you do here
today
do not let us and by us i mean all of us
all of humanity
down
so congratulations you are about to take
part in the greatest science adventure
at the greatest applied sciences company
on earth this is important work
and you are just the genius to do it
god gave you these gifts
i'm giving you the opportunity to use
them
well here's your lab i don't mind
telling you we're excited up here moon
landing excited newton einstein wait a
minute
that's not right
i think i put the wrong tape in hold on
good luck
world's best scientific okay here we go
you and the overalls get to work or
you're fired
they don't give out overalls anymore
anyway my name's grady you can call me
that i mean let's do introductions later
you should really already be
honestly i'm surprised you're not fired
already
anyway uh you are a
papa
product inspector
that is your inspection desk there in
front of you you will be inspecting uh
okay uh doesn't say anyway something is
going to come down the conveyor belt
whatever it is
make sure it works once you've done that
keep doing that that's the whole job
anyway just remember the important thing
is to have fun on your own time before
you come in otherwise it's just
it's it's real bad here
it's fine
you'll probably be fine
good luck
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i knew it i i left the vlog you got it
steps up that is how you inspect the
toilet i hope you were paying attention
because i'm not saying any of that twice
look it's not rocket science it's not
even toilet signs here's everything you
need to know see that light on the wall
if that light goes on you're fired
okay good you heard the important part
wait wait hold on have they all been
smoking
you know what it's not our job to test
if the toilet's on fire right just do
your regular thing like normal move it
down the line and then it's somebody
else's problem
you think your job's bad
i mean
do you hear that hold on let me take a
look
can you get me out of here please thank
you
nope i'm just wet now
[Music]
no
it's working keep pressing the button
just test it get it out of here
so
first off
i i think we're in a lot of trouble here
now i also think we're going to be rich
because i think he just admitted
something
okay here's what we're gonna do i'm
gonna go work on this
in secret
just you go back and pretend to go back
to work right like it's gotta look good
i mean just pretend the most you've ever
you know what just go back to work
actually yeah that works
i'll be back
[Music]
so
[Music]
hey i'm back yeah i'm back uh first off
you did awesome pretending to calibrate
all those toilets the best all right are
you ready for this
presenting
[Music]
no not those buttons press the new
button yeah
presenting the aperture science turret
go on take it for a spin
the controls are right there on your
desk
i mean right the controls are right
there
go ahead
and just yeah there you go just ease
into it nope yeah and i haven't even
showed you the best part here's the best
part
left trigger to open the wings
shooting
you know what though i mean you're
definitely going to kill yourself with
it pointing at you like that so let me
just turn it around
all right shoot again don't worry it's
safe i mean this time this time it's
safe last time it wasn't you almost died
wow
holy moly man that is great
oh man the turret broke that was the
only one too
but don't even worry about it because
here's what i've actually been working
on
ta-dah
introducing the mark ii
this is what i spent most of the six
months on it was one month for the first
turret and then like five for this bad
boy
oh man you gotta take my picture with
this uh the desk should have a camera
built into it
are you taking the picture
i'm posing for right now this is my
posing face not my regular face
okay good moment recorded for all the
history books now for the fun part you
are gonna take it for a spin here let me
turn it around
okay normally i'd walk you through
everything but i think you get it let's
just open everything at once and see
what happens
wow
right
oh this is great this thing shoots so
good okay apart fell off keep going
all right something else fell off you
can still shoot everything else don't
even worry about it
okay quite a bit's falling off
okay go quick keep shooting you're not
doing this this is a structural
engineering problem it's on me you're
doing great
i finished the glue i'm 99
it even looked cheap when i bought it i
remember looking at like ah spend the
extra dollar and yep here we are
wow all right that so some of the stuff
i put on there just didn't work
most of it like 90
or even higher maybe but
some of it worked great
so all we have to do is keep the great
stuff and then we then we can
so
okay
that's the police
so one of us needs to streamline this
turret right and one of us needs to take
the fall for shooting up the warehouse
because there
this is a lot of damage and they're
going to look into this
which job what shop do you want how
about i fix a turret and then you take
yeah i'll do that for you
remember if anyone asks you don't know
me okay
don't
say
anything
[Music]
hey
well i mean wow you are the best
thanks for keeping your mouth shut and
doing your time
i mean it was way more time than either
of us were expecting i don't know what
was in those boxes we blew up but they
were wow were they mad
anyway i promise you're not going to
regret this now let's get you out of
here given that the offender has
faithfully observed the rules of the
institution offender has been granted
supervised early release
please sign for your possessions inmates
possessions are as follows
desk
one
inmate must state their name
print their name
then sign their name
after the tone state your name into the
desk
[Music]
moving on
now
[Music]
type your name
moving on
now sign your name
as a condition of supervised early
release parolee and desk agree to report
within 15 days
hey don't listen to her you don't need
to worry about reporting to your parole
officer
guess who spent the last 18 months
getting his probation agent licensed
through the mail yep me that's right i'm
your parole officer
i mean not just you i'm managing like
seven guys on parole right now but
they're basically reintegrated back into
society
well not tony he's struggling a little
but anyway that's all i was doing i got
something to show you let's get out of
here
it is never too late to met
you are both free to go
oh uh bring your desk
okay i streamlined the turret while you
were gone
introducing the mark three
ta-dah
so i got rid of all the parts that fell
off and just kept the stuff that worked
i mean it was totally over engineered so
it just does one thing now it shoots
it didn't need a satellite dish that was
just dumb
here try tried on these appliances i
found they were just lying around in the
housewares research department
in a locked room
[Music]
i like that tattoo i mean did you do it
yourself it's like a is it a dragon
holding a knife it's nice
the more i look at the tattoo the more
i'm thinking we should both have it
because then we'd be tattoo bros anybody
would look at us and know we are friends
you think you'd give me the same tattoo
would that be weird
it would be weird on the same exact one
all right i'll think
what about like a robot arm coming out
of the side of my head and it's holding
a wrench so you got the dragon in the
knife and mine's similar but more robot
themed
man that'd be so cool
oh
speaking of being cool i've got
something even better to show you
gyroscopic controls
it's real easy just pick up the desk
tilt it around to aim and keep that
thumb on the right thumbstick and you
shoot with the right trigger like normal
go on try
it's really easy
how much did the tattoo hurt
when you gave it to yourself did you
have the proper tools
i would bet not actually
now that i'm thinking about it
you probably
another tattoo idea i just had instead
of a robot hand coming out holding a
wrench
what if it was like a skeleton you know
so you're looking at it like what's he
trying to say is he human on the inside
or does he have like a skeleton trapped
in him
you know what
skeleton arm tattoo i decided that's the
one i want so when we get a free minute
i'll find a pen and we can eat up that
light
all right everything checks out this
thing is
perfect i think we're good to go here
so
i was saving the best for last
but while you were in jail i got us a
meeting to show our turret to cave
johnson that's right the owner of the
company
no pressure but if he likes this
he's going to make us rich
forever
are you ready let's go
[Music]
[Music]
what do you do with your share of the
money
i know what i'm going to do is pay off
the money i borrowed to make this turret
like immediately paid off
are out i mean
i'll be in some real trouble
plus the vig
i have to pay that too
does it make sense to you that the vig
is more than what i borrowed in the
first place it doesn't seem like it
that's weird
somebody overrode the controls
hold on
[Music]
huh that's one of the appliances i stole
from housewares
oh
an
jesus
man he got that turret good huh good
thing i brought a couple spears
i knew it it's the housewares department
how did they find out about our target
i can't believe it they stole our idea
and now they're going to kill us with it
how squares man
we're never going to stop
anymore we know they're coming but i
don't
think they're going to stop coming
though we need to think of something
else
i really think they're going to keep
coming for like
basically forever
housewares man can you believe it those
guys are such pieces of what did we ever
even do to them
so
oh there is some kind of switch back
nice one i got the elevator working
again we have another 80 floors before
we get the cave we're not going to
survive 80 ambushes in a row
your desk should have some buttons on
the underside of it those fire the
rockets they got built into the desk
they put those on their standard now for
safety reasons
so if you hit all four buttons at once
engaged
here we go
we are go for launch in ten
nine
eight
7
modesty panel set to flight
configuration
okay really nice work good shooting i
think we're good from here they probably
gave up i haven't given up by now
okay
let's go show this thing to cave
also i do have one quick confession i
didn't actually get an appointment with
cave johnson i lied about that
but it turns out i didn't know this it
turns out nobody's seen him in years
i did know it when i lied to you about
our appointment but it was still pretty
new information anyway i'm not gonna lie
to you anymore
[Music]
i think he might be a millionaire
recluse now
so
be ready for that
there might be a lot of jars
hello
mr johnson
let's just go in
mr johnson are you here
hey there
it's me
cave johnson
no no not behind the giant head i am the
giant head i'm gonna level with you
a few years back
hey hey hey i can't talk over the sound
of you shooting me do you want me to
tell you why i'm a giant head or not
right where was i
giant head riddled with disease
ah
now i remember i'm gonna level with you
a few years back i got real sick
body riddled with disease i was a goner
threw every dollar i had at it told
those eggheads hey hey kids make me live
forever now i know what you're thinking
you gave the smartest engineers on earth
a blank check to make you immortal
and this is what they came up with a
giant head
off by a mile no they figured out how to
put my consciousness in a computer
that's what's in the giant head
their first plan was to put me in a
regular brain size computer then they'd
put that in a robot body and hey presto
well turns out you can't fit an entire
human mind in a computer that small
all i could do was tell time and know
what my name was so they kept making it
bigger big enough to cram every last bit
of me into this thing what happened to
my robot body still under the head
somewhere all crushed up couldn't
support the weight so the lab boys put
me in the big head switched me on and uh
i don't know i panicked killed a few of
them said i'd kill more if they ever
came back
honestly i regret that now
anyway that was four years ago been
trying to get somebody's attention ever
since
get their butts up here and end my
suffering
now don't worry about me
it's been a full life
but we're done here
i'm itching for the next step heck i'm
excited about it
fine fine fine i'm trapped in the head
i'm sad you're fired at the end if
you're not gonna help get out of my
office wait
what is that thing it's something the
two of us invented sir we came up here
to show you i think it might be the
answer to your problem huh
fine you're provisionally unfired let's
see it
show him partner
well
i'm waiting
look i get it it feels weird to shoot at
the boss but it's what he wants
whoa that'll work
i'll be honest i thought you were two
lunatics who dragged a toilet up here
but you are geniuses
they called us geniuses
we need to find his weak spot
son this thing's made of clay it's all
weak spot
keep going
oh no what you're made of metal sir so
shoot the metal
is it working
i'm in the head i can't see it's working
great sir
it doesn't feel like it's working but
i don't think it's working but it keeps
you let's make them happy
hey you see that i think that's his
power source
up here we go
powering down
the great beyond
well i'll give you two credit that is
one hell of an invention
you did it
you figured out how to end my suffering
all right
suffering ended in three
uh
you're both fired
i'm gonna need your key cards just lay
them down in front of the head
not too close to the chin or i won't be
able to see them
you know what
it just occurred to me
that the only person who knows k johnson
asked us to kill him is
now dead
yeah
do you know what the punishment for
murder is
they told us in parole officer school
you're not gonna like this uh it's life
your whole life in
prison we should
yeah we we should leave don't touch
anything
and bring the desk
[Music]
morning charlie it's me
gary gary your boss keep inspecting
those toilets good work good stuff
good
hey it's just me great
yeah just like yesterday man this
witness protection program is great
i don't know why we didn't turn state's
evidence against those loan sharks in
the first place we don't have to pay any
of the money back we got cool new names
i like yours a lot by the way
you know
come to think of it you think they'd
move us to another state or give us new
jobs or something
feels like everything is exactly the
same
except our first names
ah you know what they know what they're
doing anyway see you tomorrow charlie
so
[Music]
oh
[Music]
um
oh
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you